des formes répétitive des couleurs vives
quelques illusions à guyancourt enfants
et parents s'essaie à l'art optique un
courant artistique né dans les années 60
aussi appelé aux parts c'est un courant
artistique qui vise à donner donc une
impression une illusion soit de relief
et de profondeur soit de mouvement dans
quand on regarde une oeuvre ou un
tableau coloris eux mêmes leur image
pour se rendre compte très bas que eux
aussi sont capables de faire ça et que
ça donne à sa troubles du spectateur
jouer les victor vasarely grande figure
de lot parts le temps d'un atelier
proposé durant les vacances d'automne ce
moment se veut avant tout un temps des
changes en famille c'était l'occasion de
faire une petite activité avec avec ma
fille très satisfait on s'amuse il ya du
matériel à disposition
on a des profs sympa ça va plus les
légendes optique que nous c'est
vaguement je faisais je fais des trucs
avec ma grand-mère des fois une petite
boîte à jeux mais c'est tout doucement
on développe en fait des axes des
ateliers parents enfants cela d'abord
dans le premier objectif c'est que le
parent puisse le papa ou la maman puisse
faire des ateliers profiter de ce moment
là avec son enfant dernier atelier
vendredi 3 novembre une exposition sur
les illusions d'optique est proposée
jusqu'au 10
à la maison de quartier mono les oeuvres
des participants viendront la compléter